in this country a man accused of
shooting five of his neighbors including
a young boy is now Behind Bars Francisco
orapeso was found less than 20 miles
from where the shooting occurred he was
hiding under a pile of laundry when
police got him officials say a call to a
tip line LED them to him and that
several other arrests have now been made
Janet shamlin is outside the San Jacinto
County Sheriff's Office with more on the
story Janet good morning to you
good morning after four days of
searching for him the suspect is in
custody here in the county jail this
morning and our authorities are telling
us the arrest came very quickly within
90 minutes of getting that tip he was in
handcuffs
this is the moment Francisco oropeza was
led away in handcuffs ending a
nationwide manhunt authorities say a
call to an FBI tip line LED them to a
home in the nearby town of Cut and Shoot
Texas U.S Marshals FBI we had attack
team
they all meandered over there and uh
found found that that tip to be true the
arrest happened about 16 miles from
Cleveland Texas where the 38 year old is
accused of going to his neighbor's home
and killing five people with an AR
styled rifle Friday night before fleeing
On The Run for the last four days he was
caught hiding
in a closet underneath some laundry they
effectively made the arrest he is
uninjured bottom line is we now have
this man in custody authorities say the
incident happened after the suspect's
neighbor asked him to stop shooting his
gun in his yard because a baby was
sleeping
Wilson Garcia's wife and nine-year-old
son were killed the boy was the youngest
of the victims all from Honduras
officials say they hope the arrest will
give closure to their loved ones I hope
that this will bring them some comfort
and they could grieve
and we just got some new information
from the sheriff's department they say
in addition to the suspect being under
arrest they've arrested several other
people who helped him hide
Jenna thank you